[Music]
the trick to cereal is keeping 70
percent of it above the milk this
blanket statement presumes that all
cereal has the same absorption rate 70
may make sense for corn flakes or
cheerios but you definitely want to land
somewhere between 50 to 60 for fruit
loops or cocoa puffs and god forbid you
veer into shredded wheat territory and
end up with one of those big old ted
lasso biscuits you don't want to let
that thing soak for five days minimum
maybe in a mixture of equal parts
vinegar and dish soap after which you
toss that [ __ ] in the trash and figure
out what you're doing with your life
it's like the intergalactic version of
ups but less off-putting throwing shade
at ups and pretending like fedex and
amazon also haven't been leaving
packages at the end of my driveway and
outside of the fence our tv signals take
light years to reach this planet nobody
tell them that braveheart wins first off
a light year is a measure of distance
not time second off how about a spoiler
alert rick i'm only up to 1987 on my
academy award re-watch and i feel a
little lost because i haven't seen the
first emperor yet what the hell is a
bird person he's rick's best friend
jerry said what not who and even then
bird person is much more than just
rick's best friend he's
so
many things weddings are basically
funerals with cake cute marriage equals
death cliche but if that were true then
funerals with cake would have to
basically be weddings and speaking from
experience i can tell you they are not
you just say what's in your squanch and
people understand oh okay well
squanching squanches before casually
squanching about some squanches is
exactly the kind of squanch that makes
me both squatch and squanch this show
and with all my squanch i can't
squanching squanch how i squanch about
the squatchingly squash bit of narrative
squanch am i right
maybe it's possible that rick and family
beat jerry here but i have no way to
prove it either way so i'm gonna send it
to be safe yeah because i'm an [ __ ]
you say you get it but i'm scared you'll
keep doing it title of my sex tape look
here's some humans you can practice on
title of the sequel to my sex tape
bloodridge on clap flaps third moon show
uses a variation of the word flap cliche
sounds like you and my dad have a long
history together this conversation gives
us insight into beth's fractured
relationship with her father as well as
her insecurities and deficits and the
interplay between all three but it also
gives us some hilariously delivered
expositional backstory about bird person
and rick the strange thing is i'm not
even mad about the exposition in fact i
welcome it what is wrong with me bird
person
you are my seed
my worm my earliness surely one cannot
be both the seed and the worm plus
lateness is generally more common when
the first two come into play pulling out
someone's innards even jokingly i am a
cyborg photographer just act natural
this is a candid shot i'm not sure if
the cyborg gaze is problematic or not
but until i can collect more data i'm
gonna assume it's a precursor to
terminator salvation and i'm doing
everything i can to prevent that from
happening again
writers didn't save this joke for it's
rick sanchez in the temple of squanch
episode also they really turn this joke
on its head being nice is something
stupid people do to hedge their bets you
know as funny as it is this is the kind
of [ __ ] that serves as a driving force
behind the show's toxic fandom and if
you're offended by that it's fair to
assume you're part of the problem now
you may be thinking that was a mean
thing to say well being nice is
something stupid people do to hedge
their bets
bird murder
birder
the laser fire from these blasters
killed bird person but barely leaves a
scratch on what we can assume from the
instrument and location are referred to
as baseballs squanchy is a dick to
someone's balls for no reason this
catering space fan has super convenient
worm-based countermeasures also the
smiths are super lucky the galactic
federation hasn't realized the benefits
of spaceships that don't immediately
explode when they slightly bump into
each other when they develop that
technology rick will really have to pull
some signs out of his ass [ __ ] you
summer saying [ __ ] you to your
granddaughter well at least in this case
you can't save fu to your granddaughter
we already covered this morty say you
don't watch tv sins without saying you
don't watch tv sins now who wants to go
shopping for a brand new [ __ ]
world elon musk and jeff bezos making
plans for the weekend
if the smiths think a star screaming for
42 hours is the worst of it wait till
they see its coronal mass ejections
after eating a space burrito maybe i can
buy that the space fan had a tv handy
and the rick had some sort of
interdimensional cable thumb drive with
him or something i mean i don't want to
buy it but i'm gonna try to get past it
however i do not buy that they build a
[ __ ] log cabin in this short amount
of time also i've decided i can't get
past the working tv and cable signal
thing so
we discovered a species of tiny pig off
the coast of new australia we'd offer
you some but we hunted it to extinction
for breakfast i know the whole joke is
that living on this tiny planet is
clearly not sustainable however the idea
that not only rick the smartest man in
the universe but the entire family
excluding jerry of course wouldn't have
foreseen this food shortage as a problem
is pretty laughable especially when you
consider that later in the show rick
casually goes to a bar before turning
himself in surely they could whip up
some disguises to pick up groceries at
the nearest intergalactic grocery store
morty effortlessly sending this frisbee
around the entire planet raises multiple
questions about the gravity here and how
they're able to walk around like normal
alright just the one question i guess
morty if you go to where there's a bunch
of ice cream and then you don't come
back you haven't actually gotten ice
cream you've just gone where ice cream
is rick would be scratchingly good at tv
sense where's the van morty
it's over the horizon in the driveway
i'm not gonna send rick asking morty
where the van is when he's the only
person we've seen driving it i'm not
gonna send rick asking where the van is
before checking the driveway but i am
gonna send the fact that they built a
driveway for a space fan instead of a
launching pad i'm jerry smith and i love
sucking big sweaty boners and licking
disgusting
furry testicle sacks ah
okay
only rig and morty could have stuck the
landing on the transition from that
statement to the use of non-diegetic
music to convey turmoil and the general
emotional toll of rick's life of the
galactic federation
i feel better show expects us to believe
that medicine works this quickly and as
someone who's sitting here an hour later
waiting for his edible to kick in i'm
calling bullsh and this unicorn that's
been hanging out with me for the last
hour totally agrees yeah what are you
waiting for
everything i really hate cliffhangers
like this we're gonna put a character's
fate in jeopardy at least make it
someone that we might believe will be
stuck in this prison or killed we know
rick won't be killed and we know rick
won't spend the rest of the series in
prison this cliffhanger is all kinds of
squanch
the blatant disrespect for this pizza
this might actually bother me more than
the cliffhanger nonsense why would you
do that to a piece of pizza that did
nothing to you because you're a monster
that's why
don't even start with me franklin okay
you need to walk away from this asap
i squant my family uh what i do i squant
my family frank you disgust me you
disgust everyone you know you're not
being very supportive of a bird person
on his big day how about this shut your
mouth round kick your teeth down your
throat and i'll shut it for you squatch
this mofo not using it right joe ah it
sounds like you and my dad have a long
history together wish i could say the
same with all due respect what the [ __ ]
are you talking about
that's not right
you know when i first met bird person he
was
listen i'm not the nicest guy in the
universe and for the record my name's
not ted peterson it's han solo named
after the man who made the kessel run in
less than 12 parsecs and i am a burger
like my father before me also i want to
tell everyone here that i've got a
pretty huge new kids on the block tattoo
on my back the heads are warped but you
guys it's funny
how it feels to chew five gum
stimulate your senses
welcome to earth